à tort
[Musique]
mais a dit m
mme lagarde
encourus
[Musique]
demain
m
et beaucoup
[Musique]
voilà ça fait mal
à paris c'est c'est la tour eiffel c'est
en effet au sommet de la tour eiffel
quand j'étais au sommet de la tour
eiffel
oui
et j'ai voulu voir tout parce que l'a4
côté sur la tour eiffel
j'ai passé j'ai fait un tour toutes les
quatre côtés et je regardais les toits
des maisons les ai tous les fleuves la
scène qui coule et 600 700 c'est la même
scène que j'ai gardé que j'ai mémorisé
je peux faire un jeu je pense que je
peux pas l'oublier parce que c'était la
plus belle vue que j'avais jamais vu
cela
écrites pendant un moment
j'ai une impression ce coup ci je volais
quoi je volais ou parce que
j'étais dans le 7ème ciel ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
derrière moi à gauche et à droite si tu
vas par la cellule aux béquilles ce
temps déjà seulement d'autres côtés
devant moi c'est kirghizstan par exemple
si tu veux à part la part si tu passes
de kilomètres de ma maison je trouve en
ouzbékistan si tu veux si tu vas à
gauche donc si tu passes à peu près de 8
km tu seras un homme existant est
derrière moi c'est à peu près de 10 km
après ac 2-2 qui s'en est ce pour ça que
le bazar et a trouvé son lieu et si je
crois parce que les marchandises les
ventes les acheteurs ils sont presque
toutes les fautes les acheteurs il vient
de le semer qui ce temps est bien de
l'ouzbékistan pour acheter des tissus
des chaussettes comme ça des trucs qui
sont moins chers qu'un aspect qui ce
temps et donc pour ça il ya des gens qui
font de dix ans on peut les appeler les
contrebandiers
mais je crois qu'ils sont pas des contre
ce peuple parce que c'est pas ça peut
être ça peut pas être et que un rouleau
des tissus soit un paquet des chaises
des chaussettes ils peuvent être quelque
chose qui
qui de la contrebande qui sont de 2,4 ou
en haïti a pas de soldats avec quelque
chose comme ça qu'ils qui serait pas on
dit que la route est ouverte
et alors partez le fond comme ça et il
ramène jusqu'à la frontière
et il ya d'autres chauffeurs ouzbeks qui
le reprennent qui le ramène juste aux
grandes villes de notre république
voisine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça va
m
bonjour merci beaucoup
[Musique]
d'abord qui est du service aujourd'hui
et que donc aujourd'hui je vois déjà les
allemands merci c'est ma vie
le 2 à lombez
saint hippolyte à pourvoir fait de ne
pouvoir réaliser des moulages je peux tu
me cale astana maroc pouvoir le week-end
l'allemand même que c'est qu'elle est un
homme à prendre ma voiture je peux
écouter jusqu'à les années 80 les autres
tout est sacré
à la ferme à la campagne blanche latin
cela près que le jeune homme qu'ils ont
[Musique]
récompensé les actifs même secours est
ce la raison de la corriger
d'origine jégo en douze ans la durée
j'avais tout le monde la famille
la delta veut rester une politique que
ce soit mais ce que tu peux nous réciter
une poésie parce que tu es en retard
quelle police est venue réciter une
échappée
alors ma jambe
[Musique]
maison à part il n'y a pas trop bien
mon moment mon du monde
l'histoire des jardins bien neige qui a
touché notre cinéma
[Musique]
beaucoup
ce jour là
hahaha
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
athome natura brasil yamaska the bottom
ménude à l'os pour ses joues rouges et
noirs
raboter mal partout
[Musique]
attendue des microséismes association
est née avec une partie du golfe nasa
musique battant 7-6 7/4 en bateau at il
dit
et là c'est leur fils raconte je me
disais indique la société
puisqu'on connaître vos agendas ne nous
sera opérée cet article
parce que
nous avons donc mis en examen
vous
m
genzyme gagnait
la torre siège et l'a 319 m
les trois plateformes
la dépense de toute sa jeunesse à
l'école c'est on est entièrement à
l'apprentissage du français
ici je n'avais jamais travaillé comme ça
je n'aurais pu j'aurais pas pu apprendre
le français
moi aussi je pense il dit qu'il est
assez vieux pour la france il est
toujours rigoles qu'il a beaucoup péché
mais quand même je pense que au bout de
son coeur est à quelque chose s'il est
oui son verre mais j'ai pas sûr que ce
soit le petit parce que c'est un rêve
qui ne quittera jamais jusqu'à sa mort
je rêvais habiter en france qu'à tout
moment on vient de prêter quelques temps
mais
mais il est difficile de le réaliser
c'est pourquoi je le lâche et tous les
après je ne lâchais après que je visais
la france parce que c'est trop c'est
trop pour une pour une personne comme
moi c'est le trot français français
c'est quelque chose qui est dans mon
coeur je peux pas voter parce que si
même j'ai pas de chance à l'aide du
logiciel la france en consommer je jure
si je travaille quand je construis mais
je sais par les mutations mais je leur
ai fait je tâche d'imiter mon professeur
ski
tout ce que je possède
en ce qui concerne le français moi c'est
la classe de français c'est une petite
france c'est une toute petite france
dans lesquels le premier qu'on s'y mêle
très peu stressé pendant 45 coopérants
finissait s'est jetée est de le faire je
tâche de créer une ambiance française
dans cette classe tout ce que je peux
faire résonner
voilà
[Applaudissements]
mon rêve jouer les rôles dans les films
être célèbre populaire oh merde
saleh j'espère beaucoup que qu'un jour
j'aurai la chance de visiter la france
n'importe quand je rêve qu'un jour
j'aurai j'aurais assez d'argent pour
aller voir soit pour prendre du tass de
du t1 à paris pour ça seulement et donc
est mon rêve que mes filles mes enfants
fassent leurs études
je veux que mes enfants fassent leur et
id europe 1 jour
[Musique]
je pense que mes rêves vont se réaliser
à la fois obs aux balles et par des non
syndiqués le plus proche est un
[Musique]
quand j'ai égorgé le mouton pour la
première fois j'avais 12 ans c'est mon
grand père qui m'a appris à marcher et
je l'aï alors j'ai corrigé beaucoup de
moutons à 4 5 vous tombe un jour il faut
il faut continuer le métier il faut
faire parce que selon nos rites selon la
tradition il faut la suivre le père il
faut faire tout à faire tout ce que ton
père a fait même une fois une fois dans
ta vie à mon choisy j'aurais été
j'aurais peut-être été l'ambassadeur
jean jaurès j'aurais pu travailler
d'ailleurs comme que j'aurais pu
posséder quelque chose comme ça mais
c'est pas ça n'existe pas je pensais ses
confrères qui existe entre acteurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle nassima j'habite à
amiens j'ai 13 ans j'ai trouvé ça j'ai
un père et manager spirale week-end
peuvent habiter amiens j'adore le foot
et bonjour jour à perdre en bande à xavi
a rayonné j'ai dû m'acquitter nakata
timo boll n appartient qu à voler ce
slam c'est un demi agatha le thème
bonjour je m'appelle à bosse je suis en
huitième place
j'avais la javie tard à lyon j'ai 14 ans
yar'adua conquête 50 et appliquent ne
croit il passe tandis qu'une liste
judith ce que la faute est à trois
cartons un bois journée bonjour je
m'appelle mona zidane je pense à un mini
clavier gastronomique roulement semaine
mais un bon quart d'heure
alors que le thunder bay parole ou
rouler ce cas un de lescar à la lettre
la main bonjour je m'appelle je raisonne
j'habite à rabat
même si la jactance bonjour mortman
trois communes coupat comme la route
flash et martin jeux mac est clos mais
j'ai préval jacquet par année mais la
date à michael polish nos ruelles 8 une
migros d'art crimson archer pour moi je
m'appelle holveck
j'ai géré anges
john jay jay jay o m quel adjectif tout
forme un bon double voire turin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui c'est sûr qu'il veut c'est bien tu
veux l'être quel temps par exemple il ya
eu des filles qui ont voulu être des
erreurs et des enfants et qui ont voulu
être des médecins est comme ça voilà
mais d'une côté c'est bien aidé autre
côté s'il faut pas oublier ses parents
aussi parce que eux aussi comme je
t'avais dit que tout ce que j'ai voulu
faire c'est gelé décidé avec maman mais
avec ma mère voilà c'est je pense qu'un
autre mentalité nomme n'autorise pas à
ses rêves de se réaliser
un peu parce que tu peux pas être contre
tes parents première chose
quand il veut pas que leurs enfants
un soin ve
loin d'eux dès qu'ils sont en 10e soit
en onzième classe et comprend elles
comprennent ça elles comprennent que que
le rêve ne veut pas ne vont pas se
réaliser
maintenant ils sont utiles pour ça ils
rêvent beaucoup ils ont des rêves ils
ont beaucoup de rêves
je pense qu leurs parents vont leur
autorisé comme ça
je suis à ma femme oui et elle a fait
ses études aussi à auch d'un que c'était
bien quand même temps que la langue
maternelle
elle a dû apprendre le bec aux élèves
d'un que et voilà on a des enfants
maintenant c'est pour ça elle peut pas
venir ainsi à l'école parce que et parce
que elle elle doit nourrir nos enfants
c'est bien qu'il ya d'autres choses pour
ouvrir les enfants mais je veux pas que
mes enfants soient reçoivent aux malades
c'est pour ça je sais moi qui interdit
qu'elle vient ici à l'école travailler
si elle travaille à l'école et en même
temps on doit travailler chez moi doit
préparer un repas le digne et le petit
déjeuner pour tout là pour tout les
membres de ma famille pour main pour mes
parents et c'est l'habitude depuis
longtemps comme ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je sais si elle va à l'école ça peut
être un peu autrement oui c'était ça
peut être un peu accro et compréhensible
pour les européens
pour les autres mais ces dames c'est la
différence entre mon et entre par
exemple deux c'est ce que ça chez nous
et comme ça on vit comme ça on habite
il ya des défauts et à iliad est coté
qui sont bien encore je crois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la plupart des allah qui s'intéresse aux
gens ce sont des filles et un garçon qui
parle un peu anglais celui qui est plus
intéressé mais il est difficile de
trouver des garçons qui centre ans qui
sont passionnés à la langue parce que
quand tu vois que après la 9e les
garçons quittent l'école
ils sont en train de craquer métier
comme ça en face à leurs parents qui
permet pas de continuer leurs études à
l'école est ce de même je choisisse le
métier ou la profession que les études
que continuer coûte mais les études à
l'école
il est fier et défis sont sont très très
très actif mais j'ai été plus que je
travaille à l'école j'ai vingt onze ans
a passé 11 ans ont passé et j'ai pu
enlever trois 3 apprentis un futile mais
personne n'a pas choisi le français
parce que le français s'était à la roche
en plus de tout le dernier enlève le
dernier relais c'était un garçon qui que
vous venez du croisy l'autre à l'autre
côté du ring et il a oui il a remporté
le prix successives alors qu'anne mais
là où tu as chez blue bien fait beaucoup
d'efforts pour rentrer et aussi
apprendre le français à l'université
mais n'a pas réussi n'a pas eu de la
chance tu expliques tu as qu'à ce moment
là
quand il est allé à auch pour donner
pour pour donner ces documents et on lui
a pas dit que qu'ils avaient déjà fermé
là le département de façon c'est comme
ça
et maintenant qu'est ce qu'il fait mais
maintenant la minutie et il fait des
deux portes de fenêtres mais en
classique
dans cinq ans il y aura personne qui
peut qui pourra continuer l'enseignement
du français
[Musique]
c'est vrai moi je suis bilan ce sens là
j'apprends l'anglais et le français
mais c'est mes élèves c'est les jeunes
professeurs qui viennent à l'école ne
savent que le que l'anglais et quand tu
as déjà vu que les anglaises et les
élèves sont plus motivés apprendre
l'anglais que le français ça pose un
problème c'est pas un problème pour les
élèves aux pauvres la société mais c'est
un problème pour le futur pour le
perspective de la langue française qui a
existé beaucoup de temps enfin dans
beaucoup de temps ici
et du coup il ne va s'arrêter
mais le moment est proche mais je suis
parfait cynisme et 16 c c'est la vérité
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en trois mois
[Applaudissements]
regard
il
beaucoup
davutoglu
le meilleur compteur de tournois la
saison
non
[Musique]
mais il a eu le mot
a salon monégasque calais 16 h messe
à salonique
yacine sene l'islam a pris place de ceux
de son de sa passion de sa passion la
langue française
parce que il fait beaucoup de tension
dans beaucoup d'autres actions beaucoup
de temps à l'arabe vous dire à l'islam
e
[Musique]
oui je pense qu'il a consacré la reste
de toute sa vie à l'apprentissage à
l'islam
oui
ah la belle à voir avec même un sommeil
normal
soit
[Musique]
un semi marathon
au bâton
au lait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pendant mes souvenirs souligne robert
[Musique]
à la
ça c'est ça moi je suis là mes enfants
sont elles sont ça comme ça ça c'est
peut-être un peu comme témoin gérard
collomb morita boulons monras madiot
encore d'accord voilà voilà
je peux être expliquée comme ça ils sont
mes bonheurs
je suis heureux quand je suis avec eux
je suis heureux quand ils font des
bêtises
maintenant je suis heureux quand ils
sont avec moi car je joue quand il de
monde quand il mange
quand ils sont vivants
l'harmonie
non la villa au lycée quand quelque
chose c'est c'est au gie j'imagine comme
ça c'est l'harmonie c'est quand tout est
à sa place c'est si tu vois quelque
chose à sa place c'est l'harmonie c'est
quand tu sois bien des espoirs
correspondait bien à telle possibilité d
opportunité et non je pense pas c'est
pourquoi j'ai j'ai diminué mes rêves
pour être plus plus harmonique
tu es
l'islam stade laminé à l'hôpital
parce que mon chef
nous avons un scoop est non bien sûr
mangou c'est bête chaussures toutes
parts et à décharge et est un peu de
voix est en outre signé avec miniers de
l'ordre
c'est l'ordre intérieur
oui avec la religion avec islam je
plaide m mes pensées je peux mettre mais
ce oui je peux mettre encore mais ce
soir les espoirs un autre c'est une
histoire qui a pour lui il avait l'un
des dieux
[Musique]
482 l'histoire d'amour de désir
les artistes anonymes les sculptures
haut de la rue mme tenteront de vous
l'êtes inscrire pour le ciel à venir le
venir
temps des cathédrales
[Applaudissements]
le
le monde est entré
dans un nouveau millénaire l'homme à
peau le monde vers les étoiles
[Musique]
à
écrire son histoire
dans le verrou d'en appuyer
rappelez bien jour après jour siècle en
siècle avec l'amour est la plus élevée
du tout qu'il avait bâti de ses mains
les poètes et le tronc battre on prend
chanter des chansons d'amour prométhée
toujours les mains de meilleurs
lendemains
[Musique]